ZDF live herzlich willkommen
russlandspräsident Putin zeigt sich
wieder auf großer politischer Bühne und
zwar beim G20 Gipfel bei den vergangenen
G20 gipfeln in neudeli und in Indonesien
hatte er sich ja noch von seinem
Außenminister lavrov vertreten lassen
jetzt hat er sich wieder vor den Staats
und Regierungschefs der führenden
Industrienationen und Schwellenländer
präsentiert wenn auch nur virtuell dabei
wiri Putin Vorwürfe gegen den Ukraine
wegen des ukrainekrieges zurück und war
gleichzeitig in seiner Rhetorik nicht so
aggressiv gegenüber dem Westen wie man
ihn sonst in der Vergangenheit erlebt
hat wie dieser Auftritt zu verstehen ist
das frage ich gleich unseren ZDF
Korrespondenten in Moskau der Krieg in
der Ukraine geht währenddessen
unvermindert weiter dabei soll Russland
extrem hohe Verluste hinnehmen obwohl
die sowohl von Soldaten als auch von
Material und trotzdem sagt der
Militärexperte Christian Mölling von der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswärtige
Politik Russland Stelle mit seinen
imperialistischen Ambitionen die größte
Bedrohung für die natostaaten da es
gehhe jetzt darum den nächsten Krieg zu
verhindern wie das bespreche ich jetzt
mit Christian Mölling der mir jetzt aus
Berlin zugeschaltet ist guten Abend Herr
Mölling hallo guten Abend Herr Wortmann
ja wenn ihr Fragen an Herr Mölling habt
oder eure Gedanken zum Thema mit uns mit
Herr Mölling teilen wollt dann könnt ihr
das wie immer sehr gerne tun inem ihr
die bei uns im Chat platziert oder er
schickt sie uns per Mail an
zdfheute-li@zdf.de und ich versuche dann
so viele wie möglich hier im Stream
unterzubringen Herr Mölling sie
beschreiben in ihrer Analyse die ich
gerade schon einmal kurz angerissen habe
dass Russland ab dem Zeitpunkt wo die
intensiven Kämpfe in der Ukraine
aufhören 6 bis 10 Jahre brauchen würde
um seine Armee so aufzustellen dass es
eben einen Angriff auf die NATO wagen
könnte wie kommen Sie zu dieser Analyse
na ja wir haben ähm zwei Faktoren die
diese Kriegsgefahr eigentlich äh
sozusagen ausmachen es ist auf der einen
Seite die Motivation was will Russland
eigentlich erreichen und
da ist Russland quasi seit Ende des
Kalten Krieges eigentlich sehr klar es
gibt sehr frühe Einlassungen von Putin
in denen er sich traurig zeigt dass man
durch das Ende der Sowjetunion viele
Russen jetzt quasi im Ausland leben hat
aber Russland würde nicht dort enden wo
die russischen Grenzen sind das wäre
sozusagen noch ein teil Russlands dass
das auch zu Taten führt hat man in der
Vergangenheit gesehen dadurch dass viele
Russen die im Ausland gewesen sind Pässe
bekommen haben und man dadurch auch
Gründe geschafft hat zumindest
vorläufige Gründe geschafft hat
vorgebliche Gründe geschaffen hat um
militärische Interventionen zu
rechtfertigen
was jetzt mit dazu kommt zu der
Intention Russlands quasi das alte
russische Imperium wiederherzustellen
ist die steigende Fähigkeit Russlands
industriell nachzuziehen und tatsächlich
Produktionskapazität weiter aufzubauen
sie haben völlig Recht zur Zeit steht al
doch keine Bedrohung da weil eben ein
Krieg läuft indem dieses neu
hergestellte Material oder auch das was
repariert worden ist quasi verbraucht
wird aber eben mit dem Ende der Kämpfe
in der Ukraine bedeutet das dass
Russland die neue Möglichkeit hat das
was da jetzt produziert wird und in
hohem Maße und zunehmendem Maße
produziert wird dann wieder zu nutzen um
seine eigenen Streitkräfte wieder
aufzubauen bevor wir jetzt gleich weiter
über ihre über das Szenario sprechen und
auch die die Aufrüstung Russlands vorab
einmal zum Verständnis was meinen sie in
ihrer Analyse mit ein Ende der
intensiven Kämpfe was ist das wie würden
Sie diesen Zeitpunkt beschreiben ja wir
benutzen ganz bewusst dieses Wort weil
wir nicht von Frieden Waffenstillstand
oder sonst etwas sprechen wollen wie das
zustande kommt und auch wann das ist
lassen wir ganz bewusst offen aber die
die hochintensiven Kämpfe heißt alles
das was wir in den letzten zwei Jahren
in der nicht Regenzeit gesehen haben wo
viel Material wo viel Munition und viele
Menschen im Grunde genommen im Krieg äh
entweder zerstört oder gefallen sind ähm
und wenn das aufhört wenn also auch der
Verbrauch von Material vor Ort in an der
Front aufhört oder auch nicht mehr ähm
auf dem Wege zur Front zerstört wird
dann ist eben die die russische
Kriegsproduktion in der Lage in
erheblichen Maße z.B neue Panzer neue
Raketen alles das zu produzieren was sie
jetzt schon kann was aber jetzt zur Zeit
noch zum Einsatz kommt mhm sie haben es
gerade auch schon kurz angerissen wir
haben natürlich in den vergangenen
Wochen auch immer über die erheblichen
russischen Verluste berichtet zum einen
von Soldaten die gestorben sind in
hoherzahl aber auch von viel Material
was eben zerstört wurde beispielsweise
bei der Schwarzmeerflotte woher will der
Kremmel denn die Ressourcen sowohl die
menschlichen Ressourcen als auch das
Material nehmen um ebeno stark dann
wieder zu werden ja also Russland ist
auf der einen Seite zurzeit ja noch in
der Lage viel Geld zu generieren aus den
Einnahmen von Öl und Gas auch wenn
Europa das nicht mehr abnimmt der Rest
der Welt nimmt es ab und auch zu höheren
Preisen denn einer der Effekte des
Krieges ist ja dass die Preise
zwischenzeitlich gestiegen waren das
heißt Russland kann seine Einnahmen
weiterhin in einem erträglichen Maße
halten und es ist bereit auf Wohlstand
zu verzichten das ist auch ein
wesentlicher Unterschied zu den
westlichen Gesellschaften Russland muss
keinen sozialen Wohlstand herstellen es
kann viel des Geldes was es einnimmt
tatsächlich in die Kriegswirtschaft
stecken und das ist ein entscheidender
Unterschied
zu uns dazu kommt dass Russland in der
Lage ist pro Jahr zweimal 140 000
Rekruten auszubilden das heißt also
alleine in einem Jahr schafft man
ungefähr 280 000 Menschen die an Waffen
ausgebildet sind so vorsichtig muss man
das mal formulieren uns erreichen
natürlich die ganze Zeit auch schon
fragen bei YouTube eine lautet wie kann
man nicht kann man nicht darauf
vertrauen dass wenn sich Russland schon
in der Ukraine schwer tut auch nur eine
Stadt zu erobern warum sollte Russland
dann die gesamte NATO angreifen ja das
ist eine gute und wichtige Frage es geht
glaube ich in der russischen Strategie
nicht darum die NATO quasi territorial
zu schlagen sondern es geht da drum der
NATO einen ersten Verlust zuzufügen und
dann im Grunde genommen darauf zu warten
dass sich die NATO über die Frage
spaltet m müssen wir z.B das Baltikum
zurückerobern oder aber können wir was
dann sicherlich passieren wird ein ein
Angebot des Kremmel annehmen vielleicht
eine auf einen Teil des Baltikums zu
verzichten wenn das passieren würde
würde über die politische Debatte die
NATO möglicherweise Auseinanderbrechen
der Russland müsste militärisch nicht
mehr gewinnen sondern die NATO die
zurzeit noch ein Problem militärisch für
Russland darstellt würde quasi zerfallen
und man hätte es mit vielen
Einzelstaaten zu tun das ist das größte
Risiko denn das größte Pfund das die
Nato hat ist die politische Einheit aus
der dann erst eine militärische Stärke
erwächst würde aber bedeuten sie jetzt
gerade schon kurz angerissen
möglicherweise ein erstes Ziel von
Russland wäre dann das Baltikum das ist
ein mögliches Szenario ich würde nicht
alles darauf fokussieren aus russischer
Sicht macht es Sinn einfach zu gucken wo
Europa am schwächsten ist das wird auch
sicherlich nicht als erstes ein massiv
vorgetragener Angriff mit Panzern sein
sondern wir sehen das jetzt ja gerade
auch an der finnischen Grenze wie quasi
über Instrumente unterhalb des Krieges
versucht wird ähm Desinformation zu
streuen auf der einen Seite Unfrieden zu
streuen auf der anderen Seite es werden
die Punkte sein wo man hofft auf der
russischen Seite dass sich der Westen
eben nicht einig ist was jetzt zu tun
ist und wenn der erste Quadratmeter weg
ist oder erste Quadratkilometer ist das
verdaubar oder nicht verdaubar das
werden die Fragen sein und ich glaube
dann setzt man auf die Wackelkandidaten
innerhalb der NATO oder auf die
Kandidaten innerhalb der NATO von den
man ausgehen muss dass sie in Moskau
sehr viel näher stehen als sie das
möglicherweise dem Rest Europas tun
unser reichen bei Youtube auch schon
Fragen die in die Richtung gehen was
kann die die NATO was sollte die NATO
denn tun um dieses Kriegsrisiko dann
auch ja zu minimieren sie haben das in
ihrer Analyse auch skizziert in mehreren
Optionen wie die NATO denn jetzt dieser
Bedrohung begegnen kann da wollen wir
einmal reinschauen das hat nämlich mein
Kollege Thomas gons für uns einmal
zusammengefasst wie sich rüsten gegen
eine russische militärische Expansion
die Nato hat sehr vereinfacht drei
Optionen das Kriegsrisiko laut dem
Papier sehr niedrig bzw niedrig wenn das
Bündnis schnell und viel in Rüstung und
Streitkräfte investiert binnen der
nächsten zwei Jahre oder zumindest in
nächster Zeit Vorteile dann es gibt
bessere standardisierte Rüstungsgüter
und ein starkes abschreckungssignal an
Russland Nachteile die Kosten sind hoch
in einer Zeit ökonomischer Probleme die
öffentliche Akzeptanz deshalb wohl eher
gering mittelbis hoch ist das
Kriegsrisiko wenn Investitionen erst
mittelbis langfristig erfolgen Vorteile
reduzierte über die Zeit gestreckte
Ausgaben und Bundeswehr und Industrie
müssen sich weniger schnell anpassen
Nachteile Rüstungsgüter können nur
verzögert ausgeliefert werden heißt im
Falle eines Angriffs hat das Bündnis
wenig
reaktionsspielraum sehr hoch bis extrem
hoch ist das Risiko eines Kriegs wenn
Investitionen erst bei einer sichtbaren
Bedrohung durch Russland
kommen Vorteile sind zwar eine aktuelle
Kostenentlastung und eine wohl hohe
öffentliche Zustimmung zumindest wenn
auch der Ukrain Krieg in den Hintergrund
rückt aber die klaren Nachteile laut dem
Papier im Kriegsfall könnte die NATO
eine Niederlage ja eine Spaltung
erleiden also Herr möling diese
verschiedenen Szenarien die sie das
Skizzieren die sind jeweils dann auch
mit einem unterschiedlichen Risiko für
Krieg verbunden welches dieser Szenarien
erscheint Ihnen aktuell für ja am am
wahrscheinlichsten ja meine Befürchtung
ist dass
die großen wichtigen Staaten in Europa
die vor allen in Westeuropa liegen zur
Zeit die schnellen und hohen
Investitionen scheuen das Ziel einer
solchen hohen Investition ist ja vor
allen Dingen das Signal Richtung Moskau
dass man sich keine nicht der Idee
hingeben sollte dass die NATO
unvorbereitet wäre da um geht es geht ja
nicht dabei darum einen einen Krieg
vorzubereiten irgendeiner Art und Weise
sondern es geht immer noch darum Moskau
davon zu überzeugen dass es zu keinem
Zeitpunkt eine militärische Option gibt
um seine politischen Ziele
umzusetzen das ist im Grunde genommen
der der wesentliche Startpunkt
die Gefahr ist aber tatsächlich dass
Europa weil es finanziell zur Zeit so
unter unter großen Lasten leidet und auf
der anderen Seite
die Kriegsgefahr möglicherweise oder der
die die Dringlichkeit etwas zu tun
wieder absinkt durch die weiteren Krisen
die um uns herum passieren dass das in
den Hintergrund tritt und man dann im
Grunde genommen zu spät ist und das
bedeutet dass man schlecht vorbereitet
ist dadurch die kriegswahrscheinlichkeit
eben steigt weil man ein Fenster
aufmacht für Moskau wo Moskau denken
könnte ah es könnte sich lohnen lass es
uns doch einfach mal versuchen
das wäre im Grunde das Schlimmste und
dann würde selbst eine späte Nachrüstung
dazu führen dass man zwar seine Armee
noch gut ausrüsten kann aber das
abschreckungssignal dass er dazu führen
soll dass der andere zu dem Schluss
kommt dass es keine gute Idee ist mich
anzugreifen das fehlt dann in diesem
Moment und wir steigern im grundeenommen
durch eine zu späte Investition
eigentlich eher die Kriegsgefahr in
Europa mm sie sagten jetzt gerade
schlecht vorbereitet sozusagen von
Seiten der NATO was meinen Sie damit
genau
na ja schlecht vorbereitet heißt dass
ich das was an an kriegsniveau an an
kriegsfähigkeit oder
Verteidigungsfähigkeit notwendig ist um
Russland von einem Angriff abzuhal en
oder wenn er stattfindet im grundeom an
der natogrenze bereit stoppen zu können
dass das zur Zeit nicht gegeben ist
darüber sind sich eigentlich alle
natostaaten einig gleichzeitig sind sich
auch alle natostaaten einig dass
Russland die größte Bedrohung zur Zeit
ist also der Text den sie eben
vorgetragen haben ganz am Anfang ist
nicht quasi aus unserem Papier sondern
ein Zitat auf dass sich alle natostaaten
geeinigt haben das heißt das ist im
Grunde genommen erstmal die Ambition
dass man das verhindern will dafür fehlt
es aber zurzeit in der Tat an an aber
auch an Soldaten in Europa an Kommandos
an an Stäben und an vielen Kleinigkeiten
Europa ist also insgesamt nur auf einem
sehr niedrigen Niveau derzeit
verteidigungsfähig und das Wichtige
dabei ist halt dass Russland jetzt schon
produziert das heißt also dass es uns
quasi einen Schritt voraus ist und
diesen Schritt müssen wir aufholen es
geht nicht darum das was wir derzeit
machen weiterzumachen sondern
tatsächlich ja einen Zahn zuzulegen und
das sehr schnell zu machen um
tatsächlich lich ein klares Signal
Richtung Moskau zu senden mhm uns fragt
Neo bei Youtube wie realistisch sehen
Sie denn die Gefahr eines gegenseitigen
Wettrüstens wenn ich sie jetzt richtig
verstanden habe dann ist in diesem
Wettrennen wenn man es mal so benennen
will Russland schon zwei drei Schritte
voraus
richtig ja das kann man so sagen ob es
in Wettrüsten ist das ist immer eine
sehr schwieriger Begriff klar ist aber
das Niveau das man erreichen will
innerhalb der NATO wird vorgegeben durch
das was Russland wahrscheinlich in den
nächsten Jahren erreichen wird m und
eben auch nicht mehr also es geht nicht
darum
einen Angriff gegen Russland
vorzubereiten sondern das was man meint
was Russland erreichen kann innerhalb
der nächsten 6 Jahre dass man das im
Grund in der Lage ist zu kontern und
damit keine militärische Option für
Moskau als plausibel als gut erscheinen
zu lassen darum geht's das jetzt in
Panzern Flugzeugen auszudrücken wäre ein
bisschen sehr simpel das zu machen es
hat auch viel damit zu tun wo das
Material ist ob man Zeit braucht um es
heranzuführen ob es schon vorortatt
sttioniert ist alles das hat Einfluss da
drauf wie verteidigungsfähig man
tatsächlich ist Herr möing vielen Dank
für die Moment wir sprechen uns gleich
noch mal und wollen dann auch noch mal
vertiefen was die Nato und was auch
Deutschland tun können um eben das
Risiko eines russischen Angriffs zu
verhindern bzw zu minimieren vielen Dank
für den Moment nach Berlin wir wollen
jetzt aber einmal schalten nach Moskau
zu meinem Kollegen Armin Körper der den
Auftritt von Putin beim virtuellen G20
Gipfel heute für uns verfolgt hat hallo
Armin hallo nach Moskau
hallo aus mosg nach Mainz Amin wie hast
du die Rede wie hast du den Auftritt von
Putin heute
erlebt das war eine sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftige oder sagen wir eine
ungewohnte Inszenierung Putin gab sich
ganz fast freundlich konziliant Elder
Statesman an Problemlösungen inszeniert
also das was wir eigentlich seit der dem
Konflikt um die Ukraine erlebt haben wie
wir ihn erlebt haben nämlich sehr
aggressiv anklagend immer wieder darauf
hinweisend die NATO wolle Russland
bedrohen die Ukraine wolle Russland
bedrohen der Westen hätte seine Zusagen
nicht eingehalten hätte belogen und
betrogen all das wurde gar nicht erwähnt
NATO USA diese Worte fielen gar nicht
auch Faschisten Nazis so bezeichnet er
ja oft die Regierung in der Ukraine all
diese Worte fielen gar nicht es war ein
ganz ungewohnter Putin Putin hat heute
dann aber auch noch gesagt beim G20
Gipfel man müsse Zitat die Tragödie in
der Ukraine beenden wie zynisch ist
diese
Aussage genau er hat ganz konkret
Entschuldigung er hat ganz konkret
gesagt wir müssen den Krieg beenden der
eine Tragödie ist und das ist natürlich
so wie du sagst an Zynismus schwer zu
überbieten aber man muss sehen Putin das
was wir hier gesehen haben das folgt
einem sehr kühlen knallharten Kalkül aus
kremmelsicht stockt die gegen Offensive
in der Ukraine der Kremmel beobachtet
dass im Westen Diskussionen aufkommen
wie lange können wir und wollen wir die
Ukraine unterstützen was ist überhaupt
das Ziel
das nutzt er das ist jetzt sein
Zeitpunkt um mal zu testen wie weit kann
er gehen kann er zurück auf diese Bühne
dieser G20 Gipfel wurde von dem
indischen Regierungschef Modi inszeniert
Zug Gunsten Putins das muss man ganz
klar sagen der hat ihm die Bühne gegeben
es wurde nacheinander gesprochen es
konnte eigentlich niemand Putin was
entgegensetzen weil jeder virtuell
seinen kleinen Vortrag gehalten hat und
dazu muss man wissen Indien ist der
größte Empfänger von russischen
Rohstoffen heutzutage und
da hat der Inder seinem Freund Putin
offensichtlich einen Gefallen getan uns
erreicht hier noch eine Frage wie
erklärt man Putins virtuelle Präsenz auf
dem Gipfel dazu sei vielleicht noch
gesagt es war tatsächlich ein virtueller
Gipfel also es liegt jetzt nicht daran
dass Putin nicht hinfahren wollte
sondern die ganzen Staats- und
Regierungschefs haben sich virtuell
getroffen ähm du hast es jetzt schon
bisschen aus geführt gen ich würde aber
s weit gehen zu sagen dass das für ihn
inszeniert wurde ich würde soweit gehen
zu sagen dass dieser Gipfel der unüblich
ist in dem Format stattfand damit er
eine Möglichkeit hat alle virtuell und
alle gleich okay ein wichtiger Punkt du
hast es gerade schon ein bisschen
angerissen also es war eine Inszenierung
und der Kremmel hat sich dabei auch
sicher was gedacht welches Signal davon
ausgehen soll sowohl nach außen als auch
nach nach innen vielleicht kannst du das
noch mal beschreiben welches Signal
Putin damit auch sozusagen an die
russische Bevölkerung senden
will genau wir sind hier vier Monate vor
der russischen Präsidentschaftswahl die
ist für März angesetzt das heißt Putin
hat ein Bild inszeniert ich bin auf der
Bühne seht her ohne mich geht gar nichts
wenn die großen Führer der Welt die
Probleme der Welt besprechen sitze ich
zumindest virtuell mit am Tisch und das
ist die Botschaft er zeigt seinem Volk
Sicherheit es ist alles wie immer
business as usual Putin hat die Lage
unter Kontrolle und Russland ist wieder
WR jetzt hat nach diesem Äußerung von
Putin beim G20 Gipfel Bundeskanzler
Scholz Putin zum Rückzug aus der Ukraine
aufgefordert welche Reaktionen sind dir
bisher schon bekannt auch aus dem Westen
auf den Auftritt von Putin
heute genau die Reaktionen sind ja
komplett nahliegend es hat ja wirklich
absurde Züge wenn der der den Krieg in
der Ukraine begonnen hat jetzt sagt es
seine Tragödie und man müsse das
gemeinsam beenden das Beenden ist ja
relativ einfach und nahliegend nämlich
in dem Russland die Truppen aus der
Ukraine zurückzieht das ist natürlich
das was der Westen fordert nicht nur
heute sondern auch gestern und seit nah
zuu zwei Jahren seit dieser Krieg ist
aber er hat die Bühne genutzt und hat
sein Statement abgegeben mhm Amin Herr
Mölling hat es gerade einmal schon in
unserem Gespräch ein bisschen angerissen
m es gibt sozusagen das ist auch Teil
dieser Analyse eine verhältnismäßig hohe
Akzeptanz in Russland in der russischen
Gesellschaft für menschliche Verluste im
kriegerischen Auseinandersetzung wie
nimmst du die Stimmung in der russischen
Bevölkerung war auch mit Blick auf
mögliche Kriege in der
Zukunft also man muss ganz klar sagen
die russische Gesellschaft ist so
zynisch und so hart es klingt sie ist an
Krieg gewöhnt also wenn ich jetzt
zurückdenke an meine Zeit als
Erwachsener wie viele Kriege Russland
das schon geführt hat in tsetchenien in
der Ukraine in Georgien in Syrien das
heißt es gibt hier keine
friedensgeneration in dem Sinne wie du
und ich das aus Deutschland sind und D
das macht Putin sich auch zu Nutze er
stellt auch die Gesellschaft auf einen
langen Krieg ein er hat jetzt z.B ein
ein es wird jetzt diskutiert ein
generelles Abtreibungsverbot einzuführen
das heißt die Leute haben eine
vaterlandspflicht eine patriotische
Pflicht Kinder zu zeugen für Kriege die
Russland führen wird Amin danke schön
für diese Eindrücke für diese
Einschätzung live aus Moskau
danke also Putin präsentiert sich wir
haben es jetzt gerade von meinem
Kollegen gehört als ja den großen
Vermittler und Friedensbringer
gewissermaßen wie passt das zusammen mit
dem was wir gegenwärtig erleben das will
ich jetzt noch einmal besprechen mit
Christian Mölling von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
hallo noch mal nach Berlin hallo alsoin
Körper sagt er hat Putin heute erlebt
maßen wie lange nicht mehr keine
verbalen Attacken gegen den Westen er
inszeniert sich als der der für Frieden
sorgt in ihrer Analyse beschreiben sie
aber sozusagen das Gefahrenpotenzial was
von von Russland und auch von Putin und
vom Kremmel ausgeht wie passt das beides
für Sie zusammen ich glaube es passt
sehr gut zusammen
wir sehen ja nicht nur in den letzten
zwe oder 10 Jahren seit 2014 sondern im
Grunde genommen seit Anfang der 2000er
Jahre dass Moskau sehr einen sehr klaren
Plan hat wo es hin möchte und wohin es
zurück möchte und dass es das nicht nur
offen sagt sondern dass es dem auch
Taten folgen lässt der Ukraine Krieg
oder der Krieg in der Ukraine durch
Russland hat ja nicht erst 2022 sondern
schon 2014 begonnen auch wenn Russland
keine Erfolge wirklich verzeichnen
konnte hat es diesen Krieg eskaliert zu
dem größten Krieg den wir zurzeit in
Europa haben seit 75 Jahren das ist
schon beeindruckend also dazu glauben
dass Moskau nach Alternativen nicht
militärischen Wegen sucht um seine Ziele
durchzusetzen
das ist
etwas wie soll man sagen etwas blauäugig
glaube ich in dem Zusammenhang mhm es
gibt eine Frage bei Youtube von Silvia
Greiner die dann eher noch mal auf
diplomatische Lösung abzieht abzielt und
zwar fragt sie Herr Mölling trauert
Putin der zerbrochenen Sowjetunion
hinterher gibt es überhaupt noch Chancen
für Gespräche mit ihm wie schätzen Sie
das ein
also nach all dem was man lesen kann in
den Quellen ist es tatsächlich etwas ähm
wo es einen großen Verlust oder das
Gefühl des Verlustes alter Stärke gibt
ähm das ist auch in vielen Schriften die
Putin selber verfasst hat oder die Leute
um ihn drum herum verfasst haben immer
wieder so ausgewälzt worden dass es im
Grund darum geht Russland zu alterstärke
zurückzubringen
und dass einem dafür im grundommen jedes
Mittel recht ist in dem Zusammenhang
wenn wir jetzt mal davon ausgehen
sozusagen von einem russischen Angriff
auf die NATO dann wäre im Bündnisfall
natürlich auch Deutschland und die
Bundeswehr gefragt wie ist die
Bundeswehr denn iher Einschätzung nach
jetzt gerade überhaupt für ein solches
Szenario aufgestellt
ähm ja die Bundeswehr ist dafür zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehr schlecht
aufgestellt ähm das was äh eigentlich
zugesagt worden ist also die die drei
Divisionen die ab 2025 zulaufen sollten
da sieht zurzeit so aus als ob die nicht
äh zumindest nicht in in dem in der
Kampffähigkeit bereitgestellt werden
können wie das eigentlich versprochen
worden ist zumindest die erste nicht die
zweite möglicherweise auch nicht ähm
sass insgesamt Deutschland seinen
Verpflichtungen die es zugesagt hat und
worauf die Alliierten Vertrauen
tatsächlich nicht nachkommt man muss
aber auch sagen dazu gehört eben nicht
nur div Visionen zu haben sondern
Deutschland bezeichnet sich selber
wieder als Drehscheibe also als
logistischen Knotenpunkt unsere
Infrastruktur ist aber nicht in der Lage
zu derzeitigen Zeitpunkt größere
Truppenbewegungen tatsächlich sicher
durchzuführen also alles das was ähm von
Westen nach Osten in einem Fall durch
Deutschland durch müsste da ist ein
großes Fragezeichen ob unsere Brücken
unsere Straßen Haupt in der Lage werden
das zu tragen und das dritte ganz weg
von den Streitkräften ich glaube das ist
ganz wichtig die Frage ist würde die
Bevölkerung tatsächlich eine
Verteidigung des natogebietes mittragen
und all die Änderungen die notwendig
sind um diese Verteidigung überhaupt
erst möglich zu machen das hat auch was
damit zu tun wie wir in Zukunft die
Möglichkeiten schaffen in diesem Land
miteinander zu kommunizieren also hat
was mit digitaler Infrastruktur zu tun
es hat aber auch was damit zu tun wie
wir in Zukunft es möglich machen durch
das durch unsere Dörfer und Städte
tatsächlich Militärtransporte
durchfahren können alles das sind Dinge
die unseren Alltag verändern würden und
die Frage ist sind wir bereit unseren
Alltag dafür zu verändern weil wir sagen
ja okay das ist es uns wert auch wenn
wir nicht sicher sein können dass
Russland die NATO angreift das kann sich
niemand es gibt keine Glaskugel in der
man das jetzt voraussehen könnte auch
mos Moskau glaube ich hat diesen Plan
zum jzigen Zeit nicht aber es erarbeitet
sich die Optionen und zu sagen wir
wollen dass wir im Grund in diesem Fall
in der Lage sind
als als Deutschland tatsächlich dem
entgegenzutreten mit unseren Alliierten
da sind wir glaube ich in dem
Bewusstsein nicht das ist das was der
Verteidigungsminister Mentalitätswechsel
etwas abstrakt angesprochen hat es geht
da drum dass die Möglichkeit eines
Konfliktes und dass wir Teil dessen sein
könnten nicht nur Zuschauer sondern
tatsächlich aktiver Teil dessen sein
könnten dass das zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
nicht teil unseres alltäglichen Denkens
ist und auch unseres Handelns nicht ist
und dass wir es wieder ins Auge fassen
müssen weil sonst steht die Bundeswehr
aber auch die Bundesregierung quasi auf
verlorenen Posten denn ein einen
Verteidigungskrieg durchzuhalten ohne
die Unterstützung der Bevölkerung ist
tatsächlich nicht möglich denke ich mhm
sie sagt Bundesverteidigungsminister
Pistorius hat davon gesprochen man
müsste kriegstüchtig werden wenn ich
Ihnen jetzt so zuhöre zum einen
sozusagen das offenbar fehlende
Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung zum
anderen aber die jetzt nicht gut genug
aufgestellte
Bundeswehr kann Deutschland sozusagen in
in diesem ganzen Prozess sich eben
stabil stark gegenüber Russland zu
präsentieren ja offenbar keine tragende
Rolle spielen oder zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt nicht das ist ja auch der
Grund warum wir dieses Papier
geschrieben haben um klar zu sagen es
gibt eine Deadline bis dann müssen wir
im grundommen fertig sein noch können
wir das schaffen aber dafür muss die
Politik eben die die Weichen stellen da
haben wir zurzeit ähm im Gegensatz zu
Putin so hatt muss man sagen viele Worte
aber die Taten sind noch viel zu gering
als dass wir ähm da tatsächlich unserer
Verantwortung nachkommen würden die wir
bewusst übernommen haben wir wollen die
modernste schlagfräigste Armee in Europa
haben davon sind wir weit entfernt ähm
und es bleibt uns eben nicht mehr
wahnsinnig viel Zeit um das zu werden
und um damit eben einen Krieg in Europa
zu verhindern weil man klar machen kann
es lohnt sich nicht ähm zu überlegen ob
man gegen die NATO tatsächlich einen
Angriffskrieg starten sollte aus
russischer Sicht Herr Mölling ich würde
es gerne noch einmal verstehen weil sie
sind ja durchaus sie haben ja durchaus
eine Stimme mit Gewicht sage ich jetzt
mal im politischen Berlin was sie da
formulieren ist ja einigermaßen
dringender dringlicher Appell haben Sie
das Gefühl sie werden nicht gehört oder
woran hängt es gerade nein wir haben uns
zur Aufgabe gemacht in dem Papier die
unterschiedlichen Informationen die
eigentlich zu die eigentlich da waren
einmal zusammenzutragen und miteinander
zu verbinden das sehen Sie auch
tatsächlich sehr schön in den
Zeichnungen die wir gemacht haben m um
damit klar zuumachen
eine Verteidigungspolitik die sich
ständig nur in die Zukunft verschiebt
und alles das was gemacht werden muss in
eine in eine nicht bezifferbare Zukunft
verschiebt die spielt tatsächlich
mit dem mit dem Risiko dass der Krieg
tatsächlich steigt ob wir gehört werden
wissen wir nicht wir geben zumindest die
Möglichkeit dieses Papier ist ja
öffentlich
darüber ab jetzt zu diskutieren das war
unserer unser Impuls hier mit die
Möglichkeit zu zu haben darüber zu
sprechen was muss passieren und eben
nicht nur bei den Streitkräften sondern
auch mit Blick auf eine verlässliche
Rüstungsindustrie eine
rüstungsindustrielle Landschaft die
diese Armee unterstützen kann aber auch
im im viel größeren Kontext eine
Diskussion in Deutschland darüber zu
haben was braucht es denn wie
wahrscheinlich ist der Krieg wir haben
viele Menschen die daavor Sorge haben
wobei ich den Eindruck habe dass die
Bevölkerung an vielen Punkten
weitergedacht hat und viel klarer sieht
auf die Risiken als das teilweise im
politischen Berlin der Fall istm ein
Kommentar der jetzt noch bei Youtube
erreicht hat da geht's dann auch ein
bisschen in die Richtung ja um sozusagen
Verbündete von Russland ich vermute eine
langfristige Aufteilung der Welt in
Brick und NATO ist das auch eine
Befürchtung die sie teilen würden mit
dem User
die Befürchtung kann man haben das Gute
ist und das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig
dabei ist noch können wir das
beeinflussen wir haben viel zu offene
Position wo man denkt wir sind
Beobachter wir sitzen quasi vor der
matsscheibe und betrachten das alles nur
nein wir haben noch die Möglichkeit
zwischen den Optionen zu wählen ob wir
sozusagen auf Sicherheit spielen wollen
oder ob wir auf Risiko spielen wollen
und das was wir in dem Papier machen ist
wir zeigen auch welche Optionen ähm
dafür da sind
ähm sehr einfach skizziert erstmal ähm
aber im Grunde genommen gibt es das
klare Signal noch haben wir die
Möglichkeit auf Sicherheit zu spielen
wenn wir die Zeit verstreichen lassen
und denken wir wollen der Bevölkerung
nicht zu viel zumuten dann spielen wir
tatsächlich auf
Risiko weiterer Kommentar lautet auch
bei Youtube von Mario sec die NATO ist
militärisch auf einem anderen Stern sie
ist dermaßen stark überlegen dass es
schon lächerlich wirkt dass Russland
ernsthaft ein natoland angreifen könnte
die NATO ist eine andere Liga wenn man
ihn jetzt die ja vergangenen 20 Minuten
zugehört hat dann würden sie diese
Einschätzung ja sicher nicht teilen
oder na ich glaube man muss vor allen
Dingen das ist das wichtig und das ist
auch das schwere teilweise in die
Zukunft schauen ohne zu glauben dass das
was man sieht die Realität sein wird in
der Zukunft wir sprechen über das Risiko
das steigt weil wir sehen ja dass die
natoostaaten selber zurzeit sagen wir
haben nicht genug Munition ja kein Staat
innerhalb der NATO ist möglicherweise
derzeit darauf
vorbereitet tatsächlich einen längeren
Krieg zu führen eine der wichtigsten
Lektionen aus dem russischen
Angriffskrieg ist dass die industrielle
Unterstützung für Streitkräfte ein ganz
zentraler Faktor ist das können zurzeit
die europäischen Streitkräfte meiner
Meinung nach tatsächlich in dem Maße
nicht leisten wie es wie es notwendig
wäre die industrielle Unterstützung ist
nicht ausreichend wir haben
hochqualitative Waffensysteme wir haben
aber zu wenig davon das ist im Grunde
das Problem das heißt Quantität ist eine
eigene Qualität und auch das hat dieser
Krieg gezeigt das heißt wenn man gar
nicht mal ein hochintensiven
hochtechnisierten Krieg führt sondern
einfach nur mit viel Masse operiert das
ist das was Russland demonstriert hat
dann kann man einen Erfolg haben es geht
nicht darum dass die NATO quasi
militärisch besiegt wird sondern die
NATO das es ist sozusagen eine der
Optionen die auch innerhalb der NATO
immer wieder als Risiko gesehen wird die
NATO kann sich selber besiegen indem sie
sich politisch zerlegt dafür kann
Russland aber die Lunte an die NATO
legen indem es gelingt tatsächlich nur
einen kleinen Teil von natogebiet
einzunehmen und dann ein Angebot an die
NATO zu machen zu sagen wir machen einen
Waffenstillstand das kleine Stück von XY
das könnte doch aufgeben das ist doch
kein Problem das würde aber aber
bedeuten wenn die NATO sich darauf
einließe oder einige natostaaten sich
darauf einließen dass es
unterschiedliche natoitglieder geben
würde diejenigen die Sicherheit genießen
und diejenigen die keine Sicherheit
genießen die wir im grundenommen
Russland zum Fras vorwerfen mhm sie
haben jetzt schon gesagt sie sehen
sozusagen gegenwärtig in Deutschland
nicht die Führungsrolle wer ist denn da
möglicherweise jetzt ihrer Analyse nach
in charge zum einen wenn es darum geht
sozusagen die die NATO zusammenzuhalten
aber auch Impulse zu setzen für eine
gemeinsam für eine starke militärische
NATO ja Deutschland ist in charge
Deutschland hat sich selber in die
Verantwortung gesetzt durch die Aussagen
des Bundeskanzlers durch die Aussagen
des
Verteidigungsministers das können wir
jetzt nicht einfach zur Seite schieben
nach dem Motto sorry wir sind noch nicht
soweit wir sind noch in der Lage soweit
zu sein und die Versprechen die wir
sowohl unseren Menschen hier in
Deutschland gemacht haben als auch
gegenüber den Verbündeten gemacht haben
diese Versprechen einzuhalten das ist
nicht einfach aber ich wüsste nicht
warum man davon jetzt ablassen S sollte
ähm und damit die Politik aus ihrer
Verantwortung entlassen sollte Christian
Mölling Sicherheitsexperte bei der
Deutschen Gesellschaft für auswtige
Politik vielen Dank für ihre Analysen
für die Fragen für die Antworten auf die
Fragen und für ihre Zeit heute abend
danke ich danke ihnen tschüss schönen
Abend ja soweit unser ZDF heute live
aktuelle Infos zum Krieg in der Ukraine
auch Hintergründe und Analysen z.B auch
von Christian Mölling findet ihr wie
immer in der ZDF heute App danke euch
für heute fürs zuschauen für eure Fragen
und Gedanken und bis zum nächsten
Mal